WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
SEAN HANNITY IS RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU AS
ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
SURROUNDING A MASSIVE, DEADLY
EXPLOSIVE IN BEIRUT, LEBANON.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE THE TAPE
UNFOLD.
PLUS, THE VERY LATEST DETAILS
FROM TODAY’S HEATED HEARING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
SENATOR TED CRUZ IS WITH US.
ALSO, CONDOLEEZZA RICE SLAMMING
THE THOUGHT POLICE ON THE
RADICAL LEFT.
WE’LL EXPLAIN THAT.
ALSO, WE START TONIGHT WITH THE
DEVELOPING STORY OUT OF, YES,
JOE BIDEN’S BASEMENT BUNKER.
TONIGHT, THERE ARE CURRENTLY
THREE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES IN
THE WORKS.
THE BIGGEST BANDS IN THE MEDIA
MOB ARE NOW BEGGING HIM NOT TO S
I’VE SOURCES TELLING ME TONIGHT
THAT HIS TEAM MISSING, CAN WE
BRING NOTES?
THEY CLEARLY BELIEVE THAT
JOE BIDEN IS TOO WEAK AND TOO
FEEBLE.
THEY ARE WORRIED THAT HE WILL BE
DESTROYED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND FAKE, CONSPIRACY NEWS
THEORISTS.
CNN’S OWN HUMPTY DUMPTY TWEETING
THAT THIS STORY IS FAR REMOVED
FROM REALITY.
OH, OKAY, THERE IS NO VIOLENCE
IN SEATTLE OR PORTLAND AND IT’S
JUST A SUMMER OF LOVE AND
FESTIVE ATMOSPHERE.
I GUESS THEY FORGOT ABOUT THEIR
OWN NETWORKS COVERAGE, OR MAYBE
THEY’RE JUST PSYCHOTIC LIARS
OVER THERE.
ONE TOP POLITICAL ANALYST, FAKE
NEWS CNN ACTUALLY PLEADING WITH
BIDEN, PLEASE DON’T DEBATE
DONALD TRUMP.
HERE’S "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
OP-ED ENTITLED "LET’S SCRAP THE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE."
HERE’S ANOTHER ONE FROM
"THE BOSTON HERALD," BIDEN
BETTER WALK BACK ANY OFFERS TO
DEBATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A REPORT LAST WEEK CLAIMING TO
BIDEN’S OWN SUPPORTERS WERE
URGING HIM, DON’T DEBATE THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW, NORMALLY A CANDIDATE
CHALLENGING AN INCUMBENT PUSHES
FOR AS MANY DEBATES AS POSSIBLE.
NOT JOE BIDEN AND NOT HIS
SUPPORTERS.
THEY WANT HIM TO STAY HIDING AND
FOR GOOD REASON.
HIS MOST RECENT DEBATE
PERFORMANCES WERE, FRANKLY,
PAINFUL TO WATCH.
SO TONIGHT, WE’RE GOING TO TAKE
YOU ON WHAT IS REALLY A
CRINGEWORTHY TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE, BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
ULTIMATE VOTER.
YOU WILL BE THE JURY AND THE
ULTIMATE DECIDER IS IN JUST 91
DAYS, AS WE SHOW YOU THE VERY
WORST MOMENTS AND WE START WITH
THIS BIZARRE SOUND BITE OF BIDEN
TALKING ABOUT, WELL, CLIPPING
COUPONS IN THE STOCK MARKET.
OKAY, LET’S WATCH.
>> WHY IN GOD’S NAME SHOULD
SOMEONE WHO IS CLIPPING COUPONS
IN THE STOCK MARKET MAKE, IN
FACT, PAY A LOWER TAX RATE AND
THEN SOMEONE WHO IS IN FACT,
LIKE I SAID, A SCHOOLTEACHER A
FIREFIGHTER?
>> Sean: DOES JOE EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE IS TRYING TO SAY?
ANOTHER ODD MOMENT, SUGGESTING
ALL SCHOOL CHILDREN LISTEN TO A
RECORD PLAYER AT NIGHT.
WHEN HAVE WE LAST HAD A RECORD
PLAYER?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PLAY THE RADIO.
MAKE SURE THE TELEVISION --
EXCUSE ME, MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THE RECORD PLAYER ON AT NIGHT.
THE PHONE.
MAKE SURE THE KIDS HERE WORDS.
>> Sean: AND THE CONFUSION
DOESN’T STOP THERE.
ONE DEBATE, HE ACTUALLY FORGOT
THAT SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS EVEN
EXISTED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE MORE PEOPLE SUPPORTING
ME IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY FOR ME
BECAUSE THEY KNOW ME, THEY KNOW
WHO I AM.
THREE FORMER CHAIRS OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS.
THE ONLY AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN
WHO HAVE EVER BEEN ELECTED
TO THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
A WHOLE RANGE OF PEOPLE.
MY POINT IS.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE FIRST.
>> THANK YOU.
SPEAK OF THE FIRST.
>> Sean: WHAT DAY IS IT, SUPER
THURSDAY, WHAT STATE AM I IN?
NO HARD FEELINGS, SENATOR.
JOE CAN’T EVEN SEEM TO REMEMBER
HIS OWN WEB ADDRESS OR HOW TEXT
MESSAGING WORKS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE NEVER, NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO OVERCOME WHATEVER THE
PROBLEM WAS.
IF YOU AGREE WITH ME, GO TO JOE
30330 AND HELP ME IN THIS FIGHT.
>> Sean: FOR THE RECORD, THAT
MEANT NOTHING.
THERE WAS NO JOE 30330 ANYTHING.
CONFUSION IS NOT BIDEN’S ONLY
ISSUE.
HIS FITS OF RAGE, THEY ARE ALSO
CONCERNING.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE’S A CLIP OF
JOE BERATING HIS POTENTIAL
RUNNING MATE ELIZABETH WARREN.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
>> I MEAN, I AGREED WITH THE
GREAT A JOB SHE DID, AND I WENT
ON THE FLOOR AND GOT YOU VOTES.
I GOT VOTES FOR THAT BILL.
I CONVINCE PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
IT, SO LET’S GET THOSE THINGS
STRAIGHT TOO.
>> Sean: IF YOU THOUGHT THAT
WAS BAD, LISTEN TO HIS PLAN TO
ERADICATE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
>> NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO RAISE A
HAND TO A WOMAN IN ANGER OTHER
THAN IN SELF-DEFENSE, AND THAT
IS RARELY EVER OCCURS.
AND SO WE HAVE TO JUST CHANGE
THE CULTURE, PERIOD, AND KEEP
PUNCHING AT IT AND PUNCHING AT
IT AND PUNCHING AT IT.
THERE WILL BE A BIG -- AND NOW,
I REALLY MEAN IT.
IT’S A GIGANTIC ISSUE.
>> Sean: NO ONE KNOWS WHAT’S
GOING TO COME OUT OF JOE’S
MOUTH.
I DON’T EVEN THINK JOE HIMSELF
KNOWS, BUT WHAT SCARES DEMOCRATS
THE MOST ARE JOE BIDEN’S, LET’S
SAY WE ARE, STRANGE, BIZARRE
STORIES.
HERE’S ONE EXAMPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW, I SIT
ON THE STAND AND IT GETS HOT.
I’VE GOT HAIRY LEGS THAT TURN,
THAT TURN BLONDE IN THE SUN.
AND THE KIDS USED TO COME UP AND
REACH INTO THE POOL AND RUB MY
LEG DOWN AND THEN WATCH THE HAIR
COME BACK UP AGAIN.
THEY WOULD LOOK AT IT.
SO, I LEARNED ABOUT ROACHES, I
LEARNED ABOUT KIDS JUMPING ON MY
LAP, AND I LOVE KIDS JUMPING ON
MY LAP.
>> Sean: HAIRY LEGS TURN
BLONDE AND KIDS LIKE TO RUB IT.
WHAT?
LEG HAIR, ROACHES, CHILDREN,
ASK YOURSELF, DOES HE HAVE THE
MENTAL ALERTNESS?
IS THIS MAN FOR TO SERVE AS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF?
DOES HE HAVE THEM STRENGTH AND
STAMINA?
IT’S THE MOST DEMANDING JOB IN
THE WORLD AND IT’S OBVIOUS TO
EVERYONE THAT JOE BIDEN IS A
MASSIVE LIABILITY TO HIMSELF, TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY MORE
IMPORTANT, TO THIS COUNTRY AS A
WHOLE?
>> Secretary McEnany: THE
LEFT, THE RADICAL LEFT, THEY
SEE IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE IS THE DUMB, USEFUL
IDIOT THAT THEY WILL USE TO
TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY AND THE
ECONOMY.
THAT IS WHY THIS IS BY FAR THE
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL ELECTION IN
OUR LIFETIME.
I’VE A BOOK OUT, THANK YOU, HE
MADE A NUMBER ONE ON
Amazon.com OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, "LIVE FREE OR DIE:
AMERICA AND THE WORLD ON THE
BRINK."
IT’S OUT TODAY, Hannity.com,
Amazon.com BUT THE REASON I
WROTE THIS FIRST AND TEN YEARS,
I COVER IN DETAIL WHAT MAKES
THIS COUNTRY SO SPECIAL, AND AS
REAGAN SAID AND WARNED US,
FREEDOM IS BUT ONE GENERATION
AWAY FROM EXTINCTION.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, IF THE RADICAL
LEFT TAKE OVER, IF THEY
IMPLEMENT THEIR STATED SOCIALIST
POLICIES, YOU CAN PRETTY MUCH
GUESS FREEDOM GOODBYE AND NONE
OF THOSE PROMISES WILL EVER BE
FULFILLED.
HOW IS SOCIAL SOCIAL SECURITY,
HAS MEDICARE, LET’S SEE, HOW IS
THAT OBAMACARE KEEP YOUR PLAN
AND YOUR DOCTOR SAVE MONEY,
HOW’S THAT WORKING OUT?
HOW’S THAT WORKING WITH SAFETY
AND SECURITY IN CITIES RUN BY
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS AND STATES RUN
BY LIBERAL DEMOCRATS FOR
DECADES?
HAS THE ISSUE OF EDUCATION IN
THOSE CITIES?
COME NOVEMBER, 91 DAYS, OUR
FUTURE AS A COUNTRY AND FRANKLY,